let me go next to our caller from the
five-10 area code who's calling today
from five one zero uh I mean yeah it is
okay great um my question is about I've
heard a lot of not not experts but sort
of political hobbyists like Bill Maher's
they say there on the Left talk about
how identity politics and political
correctness has kind of been the key
feature of turning off moderate voters
that would have otherwise voted for
Clinton but instead voted for Trump it
seems like this is just kind of a
distraction and getting away from the
core issues of sort of centrist lukewarm
policies but I'd be curious to know if
there's any truth to it you know anytime
there's a question about what is the
thing that has led to something nothing
is ever that simple so to say like there
is no doubt that there are people that
have been turned off by the perception
that the Democratic Party is too focused
on identity politics there is also a lot
of people who have exaggerated the
degree to which that's the case in order
to turn people off like we have to
understand when we're being
propagandized - there's a movement that
insists on saying the left is only about
identity politics at this point and that
makes people get turned off even if it's
not actually true so you you you
understand how sometimes that can also
be propaganda right yeah absolutely I
was wondering if this if there's any
actual evidence or you know not even any
conclusive that is there just some sort
of evidence or any kind of study taken I
would suggest that because it seems like
just solely based on the fact that I
haven't been able to find anything like
that that is kind of a distraction from
quiet I've not seen any evidence that
what what lost it for Hillary what the
difference maker was was the perception
of the Democratic Party is too focused
on identity politics now you mentioned
what I call Republican light a lot of
Democrats being just slightly less
centrist versions of status quo
neoliberal Paulette
I think that's a much more serious
critique and you've seen a lot of Senate
candidates even presidential candidates
who I mean listen you know Republican
Lite is sort of a pejorative but it's
it's true that most Republicans know
many Republicans and most Democrats
exist within a pretty narrow range of
the political spectrum you've got a
bunch of extreme right wingers now that
are outside of that and you've got some
more left-wing folks like Bernie Sanders
who are maybe outside of that but it is
a fair criticism that a lot of
mainstream politics is mainstream
because it's all sort of the same it's
Center left and center right that's a
good critique right
all right um well thanks very much I was
sorry to see the chess competition was
Jeff's trophy of the tournament was not
in your hands but next time next time
yes there is there will be another one
I'm actually I'll be announcing when the
third tournament is going to be very
very soon oh great great all right thank
you for the call I appreciate it hope to
hear from you again